[Musique]
des risques devaient chanter à la place
des arts devant 450 personnes mais à
cause de la pandémie
le concert de vendredi est devenue
virtuelle et ses prêts 2010 qui ont déjà
été vendus oui très très content oui de
savoir que tout le monde est en ligne en
même temps c'est touchant les spectacles
virtuels sont une valeur refuge en ces
temps de pandémie
la billetterie du site le point de vente
point com a mise en vente 2000
production depuis l'apparition du virus
au mois de décembre seulement près de
100000 accès virtuel ont été vendues
sans que c'est une nouvelle source de
revenus pour une industrie qui vraiment
beaucoup souffert pendant la crise je
pense que ça ouvre des yeux je me fais
contacter régulièrement par des clients
chez nous qui est qu'ils me posent des
questions chez disney parmi les bons
coups de l'année 2020 il y a eu la série
l'histoire de mes chansons mais malgré
son succès l'opération n'est pas
rentable dit son producteur a été rendue
faisant grâce aux fonds des de la sodec
qui a été créé pour les producteurs et
sans cette aide l'homme malheureusement
n'aurais pas pu faire ce projet là parce
que les lits coûts sont astronomiques
avec des billets aussi autour de 20
dollars si les captations vertu elle
génère peu ou pas de profit elle demeure
une belle vitrine
les web diffusion du théâtre du nouveau
monde sont là pour rester
car elles permettent de rejoindre plus
large public on a été vraiment surpris
de par le succès rencontré
on avait des objectifs modestes on s'est
rendu à à plus de 25000 spectateurs qui
ont été intéressés par le web diffusion
on traverse des frontières pour aller
rejoindre des gens au japon un hollande
en norvège en france bien sûr
alors on est en train de développer
aussi un marché international qui
n'était pas nécessairement dans notre
plan stratégique beyris a dû reporter
une tournée en europe à cause de la
pandémie pour son spectacle virtuel
michel rivard viendra chanter à ses
côtés un boom car rien ne peut remplacer
un concert devant public
je viens ici complètement heureux d'être
là mais il manque quelque chose
la chose qu'on va retenir de cette
pandémie le sait la difficulté d'être
aussi loin des gens qu'on connaît pas
mais les gens qu'on connaît
[Musique]
ici wifi depuis mai radio canada
montréal